I'm sure every year you receive so many
short films that are really like a first
what 10 pages of a feature film makers
film is this a good strategy well going
back to what we're discussing it uh it
yes but i will say that there is
something to be said for you know the
festival itself we are screening short
films were just complaining completed
films we want to screen something that's
you know there's a competition for a
category this is a film that's if it is
eight you know II trauma you want it to
be a completed film with drama not a
open-ended 10-page you know story where
I just it's just basically the first act
of something and just leaves you open
ended and you're like okay this film
itself isn't complete so how do we take
that you know so you see some of that
sometimes where they are literally like
the opening act of a film so what do we
do with that you know that's that's a
challenge for us like okay is this may
we want program it's just really liked
the film enough organize other qualities
where its award caliber with its Emmett
ography or to work caliber with its
editing or you know or the directors you
great and we just felt like that you
know this piss for this person can win
that potentially win that category and
things like that you know like in the
competition sense but what about the
film itself is playing an audience if
you're screening in foreign audience or
a hard to program some of those films
are very literal in the sense that they
are made you know very open-ended 10 10
15 pages in 50 min mov opening of what
it would be a feature and then the movie
is ends so from that standpoint that's a
complete so how do we judge that so you
see that often enough and that's a
that's something that you know it's
really hard to say there isn't really
good answer we've few programs in films
like that its own we have it partly
because of that you know we felt like
you know the film itself wasn't it felt
like I wasn't done and the story was
incomplete and so it's something that we
you know when a head passed on or and
sometimes we just like the film enough
where the story is going in an execution
of the film and the quality so we go
ahead and still program it but that is
the part of it that is that is tricky
from the festive standpoint because it's
one thing to make the film that way to
showcase for investors but we're not
we're not just at we're programming for
an audience it's a you know there's
it's not just like every showcasing
stuff for you know you know for for
industry alone or just for specific
batch of people try to get investing and
you know so that's not what we're doing
that's what they're doing and then they
might want to set up a screening for
those people independently with this
film like our there's the first few
minutes on my film this is what it will
be but that's not what we're doing so
that that is something that that's
tricky we see that sometimes and then
there's three honest I'm not sure you
know I it really not sure how we feel
about it I met I like it you know I have
that goal in mind and they're already
planning and they're prepping and they
have probably a script in mind they're
ready to go so they go to a fest thing
going and networking pitches here can
have this ready and it can pass on
something and they're ready to go but
the same time you know if you know we we
are again screenie short films that they
are completed film so there's great
films that are out there winning awards
the Oscar nominations nothing is
obviously an incomplete film or a first
ten pages of the script you know type of
thing those films are our short short
films and then completed the great and
their stories in themselves that
open-ended where it's like just an
opening act of something so that's
something else we kind of always
struggle with all you know for years now
i don't really know we don't have a
direct stance i don't know exactly our
feeling on it just that again they like
the filmmakers would be aggressive on to
be trying progressive before the career
but at same time I'm standpoint of the
film you know you want to screen the
best films possible and sometimes those
films because of the end of not
completed films then it may they may not
be you know up the parts of the best
films
you